at this hospital in occupied East
Jerusalem an improvised new ward has
been set up 16 beds readied to isolate
patients who test positive for
coronavirus already three patients who
have tested positive have been sent to
hospitals in West Jerusalem after an
infected man from a nearby neighborhood
visited his elderly father here the
hospital director says the Israeli
government has failed to help prepare
East Jerusalem health system to tackle
the pandemic not enough protective
equipment only 23 ventilators between
three hospitals serving 350,000 people
this is too little I mean this is why we
urge our people our our population in
each of them please please please stay
at home because you know if the real
serious outbreak goes out of control
there is not nothing we can do there is
so little we can do the Israeli health
ministry has said Co vid 19 patients
from East Jerusalem could be treated in
the west of the city and that a major
outbreak isn't expected but in recent
days cases here have started to spike
despite attempts by local committees to
enforce lockdown measures the Israeli
occupation was not happy with this and
they clashed with the groups I think
Israel must understand that we all
humanity are in a war against Corona and
it is not the time for issues like who
is sovereign here Jerusalem has the
highest coronavirus numbers of any city
on the Israeli Health Ministry's list
it's been reported that ultra-orthodox
Jewish neighborhoods account for about
three-quarters of them Israeli officials
say Palestinians have largely abided by
the lockdown restrictions they may also
have been protected by a younger average
age and fewer contacts with people
who've been overseas but there's also
been a lag of some weeks between testing
facilities being set up in Jewish areas
and in Palestinian ones more and more
testing centers like this one are
opening up for residents of occupied
East Jerusalem but the concern is that
the delay is still preventing health
authorities from getting an accurate
picture of just how widespread this
disease is Palestinian Israeli
politician ahmed tibi has demanded
greater testing capacity now he's
calling on Palestinians to use it
putting aside any worries about social
stigma we
leadership a doctors physician health
ministry in order to convince people
that it is wrong not to be tested it is
right to go and to be tested for the
sake of yourself and your community this
week the Israeli government committed to
provide testing for a hundred and fifty
thousand Palestinians living in parts of
East Jerusalem cut off by the separation
wall after a court petition by a
Palestinian Israeli rights group more
densely packed communities where the
scale of the spread has been so far
unknown Harry Fawcett al Jazeera
occupied East Jerusalem